[Music]
do you guys remember that movie 50 first
dates absolutely yeah i love that movie
i remember the title do you remember
what it's about
she doesn't have uh she can't remember
past tomorrow and so every day he has to
remind her
who she is and like their whole life why
is she so stupid she had a car accident
hell right it was a cow something like
that yeah
so she was on her way to pick up a plan
he stands by his statement
i didn't even process the whole
statement i just heard why oh that's
good that's really good what did he
actually say why is she so stupid oh
that part
well she's not stupid she had memory uh
no what is it called short-term memory
loss yeah so she can't make new memories
so for her she
her every morning she woke up she
thought it was the
the morning of right before her accident
right
dumb ass [ __ ] there's a real life story
of someone who has experienced this and
it's a real
it's a real life medical mystery because
doctors don't really know exactly what
happened
so all that school and they still don't
know [ __ ] yeah
they don't know [ __ ] like what was the
point right so who's stupid the [ __ ] or
the doctor
everyone's doctors man
yeah well in this story um so
they're calling him william but it's
fake name to protect his identity
so he his internal clock is clock
is eternally jammed at 1 40 p.m
on march 14 2005
right in the middle of a dentist
appointment so he
so that day he was uh so in that morning
he went to the gym where he played
volleyball for 45 minutes he then
entered his office to clear
clear up some emails and then he went to
the dentist for a root canal surgery
damn he's glitching huh wow so he still
thinks he's in the chair
that's the worst time you could have a
memory glitch 2020 is a rough year for
him too i mean there's
so much to take in for 2020 if you think
you're in 2005
yeah and he like always just finished
working out in his head yeah
and he was a it was the night before
attending his grandfather's funeral
so and also he was in germany by the way
so this all happened in germany when he
was there but he's actually
he's a member of the british armed
forces so he had returned to his post
in germany and uh and then that's when
all this happened right
so something happened in the middle of
that appointment
where the dentist didn't even realize
something was wrong until
they were getting like trying to get him
to get up from the chair
i didn't fix my teeth yet no he looked
um
he just looked really puzzled and like
his his skin color was
light and it looked like something was
wrong so then they called his wife he
had struggled to stand up they called
his wife
and he was lying on the couch and then
eventually
um oh they said that his eyes were
were staring and that he looked
surprised to see the wife
and he had no clue what was going on and
then by 5 pm
he was taken to the hospital where he
stayed for three days
and finally when like the mental
fog dissipated he still wasn't
he was unable to remember anything for
more than a few minutes
so all of his memory is
up until 1pm or after 1pm
after the dentist is is everything he
remembers or before the dentist is
everything he remembers before the
dentist is everything so that he has
he can't so just like in 51st dates you
can't make new memories
it's like they're saying that his
memories is
it's kind of like being written in
invisible ink that's tight so you could
be like
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] i hate you and
then tomorrow he's not going to remember
yeah it's like memento i was pretty sick
oh yeah my mentor too
wait so you so he always lives with the
anxiety of like i'm getting a root canal
today or like in the middle of the root
canal
because that's when it happened slash my
grandfather just died last night
or i'm gonna go to his funeral oh
yeah that's a tuesday morning constantly
that's so
technically afternoon i couldn't have
been while he was [ __ ] or something
yeah why couldn't it be
like going on my first date i'm excited
all he remembers he says i remember
getting into the chair and
the dentist inserting the local
anesthetic and then why couldn't it be
like
driving to his birthday dinner yeah
getting he's all excited like i'm gonna
go see him
i think it has something to do with
maybe possibly the the anesthesia but
they don't know for sure he was under
anesthesia yeah because he was getting a
root canal
that's why i don't go [ __ ] with no
anastasia so i don't go to the dentist
does that mean that like every time
he like experiences something he
remembers it for like
x amount of minutes about 90 minutes
about 90 minutes and then suddenly after
90 minutes he's
in the chair in his head in his head
yeah so he doesn't he believes he's
still in germany it's still
2005. he's about to get a root canal
and he's just like so they constantly
have to like
tell him where he's at are his friends
and family like yeah it's exhausting
being around this guy like straight up
like after 90 minutes [ __ ] i told you
already
that's how my mom treated my grandma i
was like hey you idiot
she has alzheimer's like i had to tell
her that to my mom i'm like how many
times
are you gonna tell her that i told you
already yeah
like are you [ __ ] dumb it happens a
lot with that kind of [ __ ]
like the kind of abuse like that those
people go through
because people get frustrated so then he
says that
today he only knows that there's a
problem because
he and his wife have a written like they
wrote down detailed notes on his
smartphone
in a file labeled first thing read this
so kind of like in 51st dates where she
puts the vhs tape in the morning
yeah so does it reset after he sleeps
or no it's like about 90 minutes they
say it's like what he
does he freak out when he sees a
smartphone 2005 was kind of like still
kind of early for
like fifth loans dead blackberries i had
a flip phone in 2005.
but no but that's what i'm saying a
smartphone is like
it's like just screen now yeah probably
who knows
maybe internally he's like freaking out
is there a video of this guy or anything
no
he's anonymous like they're not
releasing his identity or anything
i call him nilly willy because he don't
remember nilly
i see why i see why mm-hmm oh and yeah
also his name is william so yeah you're
right yep you forgot that huh no i
remember it was really
yeah that's how i was like that's his
name because i would be really impressed
if you forgot
you yeah be really impressed william
are you really forgetting
i mean that's not funny
[Laughter]
sometimes you just want to forget though
like yeah
especially [ __ ] this year like jesus
i had a great year i don't know about
you
i mean like worldwide like i had a
pretty good year i don't [ __ ]
people like it's all about me you know
what i mean like i had a great time
yeah that's good did you guys have a
great time that's all i'm worried about
i mean 2020 has been okay i feel like
you guys
had a blast but you feel bad about the
people out there in the world
and you feel guilty that you had a great
time so you can't
be yourself that's all it is i just we
just had such a great time that i'm like
you know i can't talk i can't say it
yeah
but i just had such a killer [ __ ]
time the entire year is open
yeah i see that you just said it don't
be a shame been a rager dude
it's been around it's been a blast
playing
happy crossings online with you guys
we played happy crossings for too long
happy crossing you never played happy
crosstalk we were all on the happy
crossings man
and that [ __ ] was tight delusional or
maybe like animal crossing
no it's happy oh happy crossing okay i
want that
but anyway so the interesting thing
about william or willy nilly
uh he the the most interesting thing is
that
in the last 10 years he has been able to
cling on to
one new fact tonight one effect
what is it his father's death oh that's
not tight
yeah that's tragic this is getting so
sad what a klingon so it's just a
it's a it's proof how
powerful our emotions can shape our
minds like how powerfully our emotions
can shape our minds because
like that grief has so they're saying
that that
that force of his grief helped him to
forge
new tracks in in new trauma
to grasp onto that fact even though
everything else is
slipping away does he have kids he does
and so he's saying
that they're saying like the wife said
when i speak to him he has
just relearned for the thousandth time
that his daughter and son are now
21 and 18 not the young children he
remembers
oh how long has he been forgetting like
this just 2005
every 90 minutes bro he says that he
hopes the rest of their lives will not
be lost to him
he says i want to walk i want to walk my
daughter down the aisle and remember it
should they become parents i would like
to remember that i have grandchildren
they're going to be like okay hurry dad
hurry
get it going get it going no we got to
go faster yeah i mean if it's like such
an
emotional like milestone for
someone's life like hopefully he does
remember that's what he's saying he's
like i hope
i can remember at least if i was able to
remember my father's death because that
was like
so impactful like i hope right but that
was like
tragic though i mean has he remembered
any like one happy memory since
no it's just that one can you tell him
stop living in the past
yeah can we get that message to him is
he do you think like he has to process
that he has this issue
every 90 minutes yeah probably so he has
to have the emotional capacity to like
not like out yeah freak out because he's
only got 90 minutes to process that he's
just undergone
one of the most horrific things that
somebody can experience yeah
every day multiple times why you guys so
tragic about this [ __ ]
he's probably like happier than we are
because he doesn't have anything to hold
you think about it that's why except the
death of his family
alzheimer's is the saddest thing because
like most people we
like they most people think that we are
humans and we are who we
are because of our experiences and our
memories and like what has shaped us so
when you don't have
that it's like who are you at this point
that's really well played
that shaped him to that moment right
yeah but then everything else it's like
you're constantly missing out on your
own life you can't grow anymore as a
person
yeah my grandma had alzheimer's and she
had a crush
on the nurse that gave her a um
sponge bath she told my mom and me she
was like i had a special moment with him
and we're like what happened she goes he
bathed me
and i was like oh you dirty dog
dirty dog yeah horny old grandma i don't
hurt your grandma dude
nikki's grandma had alzheimer's it was
pretty weird like i met her one time
and she was just like in her own world
basically and we're just all around it
and then she um it was hitting on you
she was hitting on me
and she was horny old grandma like she
kind of smelled like it was pretty weird
yeah yeah yeah my grandma was diagnosed
with alzheimer's but
she does not look it at all like she
does not seem it it seems like she has
it at all
so i don't think she has it but they
said she does
i'm like this picture remembers
everything
was that was that the disease in the uh
the notebook yeah
yeah that's why that one moment where
she remembers the past
like she remembers noah and then like
they end up having that beautiful
dance together still haven't seen it
what well the spoiler alert is keep your
ears closed
and this [ __ ] pissed me off right
because then at the moment when they're
dancing she's like who the [ __ ] are you
right
and i was like oh you [ __ ] like he did
all this work
every day and you still forget i hate
you no that's not the point
i know but that's what made me mad when
i was a kid honestly i got pissed at
that
see then why you judge me i just
couldn't believe he was such a [ __ ]
sim
yep i'm like dude you built her stupid
ass you're the one saying this he's such
a simp dude i'm like you built her
[ __ ] house she's not even giving you
nothing
name scissors it's probably too late
just just remember the
big spoiler is a [ __ ] symp simp
[Music]
one